from the Nubia family we have the Nubia
Neo 5G we're going to be playing honkai
Star genjin impact Call of Duty mobile
which will be playing with this spiffy
backbone and lastly pubg mobile the
Nubia Neo 5G is running the uniso t820
chip a Mari g57 for his GPU 8 gigs of
RAM and we've got 256 gigs of storage
everything plays out on a 6.6 in IPS LCD
screen that runs at 120 HZ and this has
a 4,500 mm battery
all right and before we start we are
going to be checking the Baseline
temperatures with our temperature gun
let's check the front currently
27 everything's doing pretty well so far
27.9 nothing too crazy
28 and all right let's check the back
camera modules 26.9 27.6
27 okay it's about the same as the front
all right so with other Nubia devices
like the red magic we have a game space
that we'll be using and let's run and
launch games from here going to be
playing Diel first and we also have our
little info section here that opens up
automatically okay now the rain game
game Space allows you to show all of
your info right here as well in little
widgets you can access from pushing off
the side here everything will be
available right here and currently this
is our FPS and then this is our bachue
we at 100% B right now so let's just
check our settings real
quick I'm going to go to very high and
we going to keep it at 60
FPS and it's not that promising I mean
currently we're only at 22 even though
we did kind of push up the 60 FPS and
let's look at the
models R looks good I mean she does but
it's just the the lag oh my gosh okay
this oh man okay okay I see you now okay
let's just try swapping characters up
not much for drops and anything no it's
still quite smooth it's just that at 60
FPS and the high set things this thing
really isn't performing especially since
it centers itself as a gaming phone so
uh let's just bring this to the combat
at least the UI is all pretty much
smooth but let's try and fight
things oh okay we're just having fun all
right let's let's throw a
bounce oh man that's kind of painful to
watch okay currently we're only at 21
FPS and the most drops is at like 19 FPS
but even then that's like that's too
low I mean honestly we are playing the
game on the highest settings possible so
that's why the performances as such but
man okay I was not expecting
this try this
off all right let's try an Alti real
quick what are you waiting for
the customer
[Music]
andr oh man okay that's not that's not
really fun to watch running into me I
don't think I need to see much more we
at 15 FPS right now this thing really
isn't doing well if he brought it down
obviously you know it would perform much
better but man you will know
Justice
go let start the ring in one more
time right nice little break okay before
I continue with jaar's Alti I do need to
make a note that the speakers are on the
side the phone so be careful of covering
that up as you can hear right
now so you know earphones and all still
the
best
go shall
never that went a lot better than I
expected
wow you been playing for about 20
minutes now and it's only taken about 3%
of battery again we are using the
balanced option so
yes let's
go there we go all right so we playing
for about close to half an hour now
without and FPS counter has not been
doing too good so let's check temperes
real
quick all right let's check the front 27
40° C
wow okay 40°
41 honestly it doesn't even feel that
hot on hand on hand doesn't feel that
hot it's not scatching or anything so
I'm I'm quite surprised it's at 40 right
now and 40 36 as we go lower okay let's
check the back it has a really nice back
it's just that performance has been
quite lackluster so far uh 39 40 nothing
Crossing 40
1 39 39
36.5 all right
interesting okay all right so with that
let's move on to our next game genin
impact all right now that we are here in
the game Space let's just check
temperatures since we're hot off hunai
styel to see how things are going
currently still at 40° C 39 39.6 things
are kind of cooling down a little bit
especially the bottom area here let's
check the back
here we go 39.4 37 39 yeah things
actually cooling down pretty quickly we
just got off honai stario so interesting
to see that it's handling thermals
relatively relatively well honestly so
with that let's just get into genin
impact all right for genin everything is
set to the highest we're in 60 FPS it's
going to be like 30ish you're kind of
unlocking it but other than that this is
the best you're going to be getting from
the phone I
have the character models look really
good
still let's switch things around a
little
bit no huge frame drops or anything so
that's that's fine now looks really good
and from there oh okay and if we kind of
just shift things
around it's relatively
okay so it kind of hover between like
40ish FPS and lower but from that not
too bad all right so with that let's
just run through Inazuma City to see how
this form handles it and using dial as
well of course as always and things are
rendering in right now 27
FPS jumping up and
down somehow the phone is handling this
a lot better than H Kai stario it's all
right it's working fine honestly oh okay
so we might have some issues with combat
like we hongkai star
real all right let's do that again okay
that was a little bit of a huge Spike
just now or rather there's a huge frame
St there just now so uh let's just see
how this thing
handles exploration in combat outside of
inuma 20 FPS damn okay let's keep
going oh man okay 17 FPS is lower so far
15 get out of
there
very nice let's get that Shaman real
quick oh Shaman's down but not the
Archer oh somehow it got smooth for a
second get out of there all right let's
do some range oh come
on and with that let's get aak oh never
mind that should be
fine
there we
go for all right
contri yeah for some reason
the the ne is handling genin slightly
better than the honai
stario which is the funny thing cuz
usually the other way
around let's get T
[Music]
out oh my gosh okay come
on very nice
okay okay so I with that it's it's quite
telling how this game is panning out and
how it's going to pan out currently
we're at
93% and FPS not doing too well it's just
been 10 minutes into the game so with
that let's just get into the spiral
Abyss let's light it
up oh God embrace the ice I think I
going to go go DPS on this thing
all right so not having a good games so
far but um see how this thing looks like
right
now okay come on B let's do it let's do
[Applause]
it over
him come
on
don't get
frostbite cool
it
R
there all right then that's done let's
just check temperatures real
quick 41° oh 42 wow okay so temperatures
on this thing is slightly higher than
honai stos which was like 40 just now 40
and also we at 92% battery so battery
really isn't an issue with this thing 35
to bought them here all right the back
41° C 42 39 41.1 38.5 and around here
35.7 okay all right one one thing I I
need to note is that it doesn't feel as
hot as the gun says it is honestly it's
not like other phones I've had where I
would I would have to really just stop
playing because the sides will get
really hot and it would start to hurt a
little bit but this this feels fine it
doesn't feel like it's 40 right now so
with that let's move to our next game
Call of Duty mobile before we continue
this channel is supported by Brands to
help us improve our content and keep us
going so stay around for this sponsored
message here at geek culture we've
tested plenty of chairs but Secret Life
gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of Forman
function helps the Titan Evo 2022
delivered the best seating experience
like no other for more information check
out secretlab.co we are hard of the
heels of genin impact we are currently
at 90% battery let's check temperatures
real
quick all right before we attach the
backbone of course 38° 37.9 this thing
actually dissipates heat pretty well so
that's that's pretty impressive but
honestly like knowing Nubia stuff they
honestly have a really good thing going
when it comes to Thermal management all
right let's check the back real
quick all right and
37.2 and on this Air 35 wow okay that's
a camera module but on here 35 wow
things have really cooled down quite a
bit that is interesting all right 35.9
35 34.9 sorry and
yeah
okay wow this thing really does cool
down quite quickly so with that let's
just attach the backbone and I think
okay this is going to fit very well
let's put it in there and yes the
backbone looks really good with the
Nubia Neo 5G as you can check the back
you know this thing fits really well
silver Graphics this is the best we're
going to get we are going to be getting
medium graphics and a high frame rate
that's that's really it all right better
Roy however we're going to be setting it
the real time shadows and realistic
scope so this is what we're working with
and let's just get into a game of BR
right and I'm a l that's
great all
right all right currently 89% battery 40
FPS let's just uh let's just jump
down okay f a habit but yep fridet
Wetland let's just get into a fir
fight
okay all right let's jump in here
hopefully we got stuff okay you got a
classic grenade okay we got a
c44 okay I think we found we found
someone to kill inside this building
all right come
on all right that's one guy
[Applause]
down
hased all right that's another guy down
in the same
place very fun
all right there's one guy
down go another guy somewhere on
here no that's
my that's mine that was my
kill H
okay oh we got a guy right
there come
on
[Applause]
all right
sick okay no invert the
controls yes here we
go what is
[Applause]
L2
okay air drop
incoming
oh
oh my God okay hold
on come
on yeah okay not the best pilot thing I
know but you know what we get it
done killed someone so I think that's
all the at this here another guy
somewhere up there
there we
go all right that's a head
shot 15 people left to
kill yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
what okay where's he at oh okay I see
now the last teams last five teams all
right one there
all
right couple more people to go are they
fighting below me oh yes they are
hello all right that's it and I won
Sicky so let's check
temperatures and take out the back door
of
course oh my gosh Okay so
there we
go
38° okay 36 35.9
34.7 all right not too shabby and let's
check the
back 36.8 38.5 around here near the
camera module I mean this is where the
chip is pretty much at here 34.9 35.4
all right we're doing pretty all on
thermals this phone actually does handle
thermals very well however um this phone
can only support C Mobile's medium
performance is the highest level of
Graphics so that's that's just one thing
to keep in mind so with that let's get
into our last game pubg mobile before
that let's check temperatures real quick
and 30 28 all right honestly we have let
the camera cool down we have let this
camera cool down a little bit and 28
okay everything is kind of at Baseline
right now and we're currently at 83%
battery check the back real
quick all right 28.9 28.5 everything is
pretty much at the Baseline right now
okay sick so with that let us get into
pubg Mobile all right so now they with
the landing page let's check our
settings really quickly graphics and
audio so um as you guys always want
smooth Graphics frame extreme 4 the
listening and we're good to go so let's
just get into a match let's see how this
neo5 G hand those pubg mobile let's see
how the frame rate is like kind of like
40 FPS that's extreme um yeah I guess
all right let's also reset my buttons
real quick before I end up regretting
everything again so so far FPS still at
is very steady 4 no drops whatsoever as
we've jumped out 82% it's really taking
up 1% of battery uh but honestly the
battery hasn't been much of an issue
even with h star and genin so let's keep
going I'm not going to fold this guy
let's hit this building right
here all right very very close very
close let's get to the front and yep
made it to the front Okay Coolio um
ump45 let's go good size phone there's
enough space at the back here for my
fingers to kind of wrap around so no big
complaints about ergonomics honestly
throughout the entire video where are
you fighting where where is the fight
going
[Applause]
on oh okay you
know okay guys down oh one more guy
there it's one guy
down okay that was really close I really
do need to he up and we have another gun
fight happening right
now
exactly the most conducive environment
for a video but you know what it's all
good I do need to heal up though
honestly come on let's grab everything
we
can we need that AK oh sh where are
you
at yo it got hot all out of
nowhere
come
[Applause]
on not making the best progress cuz
honestly I'm not used to
it okay oh my gosh okay never mind he's
it it's all that me this it's all
[Applause]
good
all right that's a squad down
oh all right five more people so one
Squad here we
go all right two
more it's just one more
guy there we
go oh my gosh
okay temperature time 20 42 wow okay
this actually he up more than honai
stario and genin wow is it 42 oh my Lord
really it actually is okay cool um
39.6 38
37.9 and 38.1 wow okay also we at 74%
battery right now let's check the back
42.1 okay this thing really does heat up
for It's the funniest game all right
let's check the back all right let's
check the
back um 42.7 yeah this thing heats up
for some reason on pubg this this phone
is kind of all over the place very
surprising performance very surprising
thermal management when it comes to PBG
damn it does heat up a lot that is
interesting this look at that okay so
with that let's just get into our final
thoughts there are many gaming phones
out there that excel at pushing out
great graphical and gameplay performance
and it's unfortunate in the case with
the Nubia Neo 5G because it definitely
does not follow suit and has some really
confusing performance ratings in our
test run can't handle graphically Dem
minded games like honkai styl and ginin
impact however between the two it
handles genjin slightly better than
honkai star which amuses me because
again it's usually the other way around
the most amusing result all this phone
is that pubg mobile ran way hotter
despite it running less intensive
settings than that of genin and Hong Kai
even though we played it around the same
amount of time as Hong Kai star or
actually you know a little bit more not
to mention it can only run C mobile on
medium settings as the highest settings
possible I will give it to the Neo that
it is a good sized and stylish phone
with great battery and thermal
management especially outside of gaming
it's a solid D driver in most cases even
though it was hitting 40° it didn't feel
like it in my hands compared to other
gaming phones like say the black shot 5
Pro especially with nubia's other line
of phones the red Magic 8 and 8s Pro
which are gaming phones as well but
handles everything way better than the
Nubia Neo 5G with this line of Nubia Neo
5G phones there's some more work to be
done because the current chip and GPU
combo definitely aren't working out for
me but hey if you need an affordable yet
solid phone that can crank out some
casual gaming then give the nub Neo 5G a
shot would you be getting the Nubian Neo
5G let me know in the comment section
below leave your questions there too if
you do have any we'll do our best to get
to them if you like what we do make sure
to follow us on all of our socials right
here and maybe leave a like and hit that
subscribe button it goes a long way have
a great week ahead and if you want to
see more stuff check this
[Music]
out
a